hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within -
we're getting right back into it we're
in a new area and we got a lot to do and
also sorry I'm one minute late I started
streaming to twitch randomly and I
didn't even know it for like 30 seconds
I was like that's weird
nothing's happening let me adjust my
camera and whatnot and it that was my
bad so hello everybody welcome and glad
to know that you all got your soup
spoons ready and no I'm not late I
started on time I just started in the
wrong place I just I didn't mean that
okay so I'm full of coffee but I'm gonna
I'm gonna drink this coffee anyway just
to get started everybody can I eat your
daily dose of soup wow that's good hey
hi welcome okay so this area is terrible
serie is goddamn awful this area is full
of nightmares monsters that want to kill
you dead but last time I was not able to
take my time with things and one more
thing before I could absolutely started
over here I just have to get this up in
my face over yonder way right there okay
Joe we're gonna get out there and we're
gonna get to it because I think we got
everything that we needed as far as
upgrades go let me just see what our
situation is going on for goop and such
yeah we're doing decently so long as I
can stab people in the brain I think
we'll be all right I'm not harm percent
sure about how that's gonna go down so
we will see yeah
hi guys yes okay I know I gotta get to
the theater but I know I'm not gonna get
to the theater right away Byam alright
so we gotta get all the way across town
because we we we literally sprinted over
here in a blind panic and uh that ain't
no good okay we're not going over there
no no no no no we're going over here
because we got to get this guy out of
here the screamy guy who blows my cover
as soon as I come over to help him
admittedly is probably in a panic but I
don't care because it ends up with me
being dead yeah stop moaning over there
you know how I feel about moaning in my
areas there's room on the roof hey
there's somebody up on the roof now
let's see what's going up on the roof
hello am i all moaning you didn't get
your daily dose of soup no no no I'm
ambushed you can I take your axe
what are you guarding over there that
crate I like the smell of that all right
well soup time I don't even know if they
have kidneys in this one but it's poor
kitty Oh No Chad every teen didn't get
your goop last time so I guess I'll get
it was this an axe gunpowder and like
the mother lode and what the hell is
this locked some of these are locked is
why they were never locked before okay
maybe the Mobius guy has the code to the
Mobius crate it's the only thing I can
imagine over here otherwise kind you
know that's just that that all of that
all of this going on here that's just
something that I don't want to deal with
mmm that's no good
I don't want to go to that show Cirque
de Soleil is really dropped in quality
lately oh hi
anyway I'm not going there yet I got a
lot of other to do before I go over
there okay bye don't climb down Wow okay
Sebastian with your floaty ass magical
abilities oh that's a lot of you that's
a lot of you did I run past every single
one of you guys probably did didn't I
oh I'm not gonna get past this guy am i
yeah I was thinking I was just thinking
about how you probably saw me or maybe
not I was thinking about how you
probably saw me no no that's I get over
Sebastian not see me I don't know
doesn't matter it's all good okay no
thankfully big birth ain't over here
which means that I'm gonna be able to
get in this bus and honk the horn he's
always my favorite activity
I love my activities one of my favorite
one wise option I'm just curious as to
why that's absolutely necessary oh well
whatever what we got going on here hello
something happening sniper rifle ammo
pouch I like the sound of that
yeah okay where is that wait wasn't I in
that place didn't I go into that diner
how did I miss an ammo bounce in that
diner I'm not sure I want to know how I
did manage to do that but alright maybe
it's around the back because preferably
I'd rather not go in there again
why okay all right whoa whoa all right
you know what you can go away now yeah
okay man she comes in out of nowhere and
I don't know why and also this time I'll
come on I just spent I just walked all
around Sebastian where you going down
there don't mess with me damn it okay
anybody anyway oh there's a statue I see
that okay I'll come back for that
bullets that and you give me that
not that I use the sniper rifle very
much but it's always good to be able to
take someone out from a long way oh oh
my Pappy would be so good
all my sacs are open in sighs all right
Italy
what is that oh hello come on hello
goodbye
grab that all right I'm gonna be sneaky
on me what the hell is in this it sounds
like something snoring but I don't know
if I trust anything that's snoring up in
here can I even get up there please oh
oh that's a dumb a dog Oh
Yes No maybe so don't see nothin I hear
something stiff stafford over there but
i don't see nothin
all right mildly concerning but not our
concern right now okay
you're not a zombie
you're Chad every teen hello sorry okay
I thought there would there we go I was
suspecting that there would be rewards
on this bus why do I hear so much of
that and yet seen nothing okay it's
gonna ignore that forever good for back
through here okay let's not get
distracted we got something that we're
mainly doing over here we're gonna find
out don't trust anything it's all in
your mind yeah I'm pretty sure all of
this is in our mind what for minds
that's the whole point so I guess the
only thing that can't be trusted is us
gives me hope no one heard that
take that all right anyway he's not
being a big baby markiplier you gotta
get going
handgun bullets that's awfully handy
okay right there outside of either
outside or inside of the compound that
we're going to anyway because this
douche nozzle in there yeah no no no no
I'm gonna go with no I go with a whole
lot of no no no no no no no you seem to
be walking towards me and I don't like
that the opposite of what I like Wow
okay dude those boxes really deserve it
who do you think you are me let's get in
here and let's not screw this up this
time we screwed it up last time because
we're in a blind panic but this time
I'll actually I'm gonna get I'm gonna
get some freaky one hey stop that maybe
I can get the jump on them maybe maybe
I'm gonna get the jump on these and get
some free goop
hello my friend okay alright you didn't
hear anything right take that free brain
soup okay good to know I still got all
the skills that pays my bills you know
we go in this place and hopefully don't
die
we're probably gonna very much die
because I don't know where it's gonna
take me check if I don't die but it's
it's a scientific fact like the farther
back my say point and the more likely I
am to die
[Music]
no not with that attitude
okay okay these guys aren't gonna detect
me know why why you'd work no you don't
see anything I find just burn on that
I'm gonna see you back in what now just
listen be to God I keep forgetting the
fire well good thing that put the fire
out huh one one to actually you know get
stomped get stop it stop your grundle
okay oh god damn it really get stomp him
stomp him can I climb up there or
something all right whatever I guess
he's dead whatever you're welcome and
they're more of under what what can I
get up there oh god damn it
we're good I love you why did you be
stupid huh stomp on him or something
geez do something worthwhile how are you
a Mobius operative oh that shouldn't
save the fire for this situation
well or I'll miss everything
oh boy you know what how about some of
some no off god I was gonna stomp you
that's not good
okay well officially out of that well
wish I would have saved something for
that
oh hey how about you uh no that ain't
good but hands
I knew who's gonna say to me someday
okay okay ow
she's no no no not again not again not
again please
just inject something woo take some
drugs you load here we go why again oh
god just save myself first
oh you were fine you were literally fine
Nora oh really
get really smoke is what I wanted yeah
that's that's what I wanted okay all
right then
all right well at least I got the jump
on this guy maybe wherever he went
where'd you go oh no no no no no nope
nope ha got your ankles and now steps up
okay
not even town did I get him did I do it
I wasted all of my ammo and I'm not
happy about it but that guy is alive you
just saved my ass
I didn't think anyone would come you're
from the search team how did you end up
here I was looking for something and
what would that be
look it's dangerous out here come to my
safe house so we can talk okay oh yeah
you had a safe house
I'm a little blood wounded I've got some
problems all right whatever
hey what's with the numbers on my butt
that used to be there
those blood numbers used to be there I
don't quite remember having that many
but numbers hmm that's a strange
situation to be in
I don't know I'll be in your safe house
does the second guy collect a lot of
goop there's some soup just left out in
these bushes over here oh I should have
opened that huh that would've been a
good strategic maneuver I would add like
fire and water situation going on there
and there was a barrel right there that
I could take advantage of but he didn't
cuz I'm doing oh well what are all
another one okay oh look at all this
stuff that was just lying around shotgun
shells oh man I should have looked you
know with my eyes before I went out into
the environment but I didn't do that
Sebastian here you got something for the
Bastian you better be coffee maker in
here oh I gotta say why can't they get
in here thanks again for helping me out
I'm Sykes Sebastiano Castillo knows huh
I've heard of you he's about the beacon
incident right you know that I'm a stem
programmer but I've got other skills too
small like hacking information systems I
know all kinds of things that nobody
else knows not even other members of the
team then you know who lily is yeah
we're all trying to find her that's why
you're here huh that's right but if you
can't help me with that then we've got
nothing else to discuss good luck hey
hold on we might still be able to help
each other out yeah mom's Missy good
look there's a bunch of stuff in here
that you could probably use and you can
have it for saving me out there
you want to hear my proposal come on
back to me wait why was I so Smith event
this is the first guy that's been like
truly like oh thank you like genuinely
grateful for me helping them he's like
please take whatever you want I'm like
yeah whatever dickweed get out of my
face I got better things to do than talk
to your ugly mug no not what I wanted
there was a crate clearly there
Sebastian your your book proclivity to
doors is not helping us in this
situation anyway I gotta get some coffee
I know there was an herb out by the
building don't worry about it I've got
too much herb in my brain all right we
can move on
hopefully number one we can overly take
care of big birth out there and forget
our sweet cup of coffee over here but
once we take care of Big Bertha then we
can go along now
Sebastian okay never mind those are
locked but I could get it open if you're
willing to help see see there we go
exchange ears how can we help each other
yeah I need you to restore the server
inside the mirror I don't like that
should be easy as long as none of those
freaks were around oh there are no oh no
no no hold on I haven't agreed to
anything yet no what's in it for me you
do that for me I can open up all the
locks supply caches for you and what's
in it for you if you get the server on I
may be able to find another way at a
union
there's really a way to get out of Union
I'm not 100% sure but I'm sure as hell
gonna give it a try
they've lost contact with stem we're
totally cut off if we don't find the
core we're all gonna die in here unless
I can figure a way out how is that
possible you really want me to waste
your time talking a bunch of technical
gibberish yeah yeah I do
oh yeah I do was turn it on how does the
server go offline in the first place all
I'm saying is if you turn on that server
I can give it a shot okay please [ __ ]
breaking apart out the way surprised
anything is working hold on but then
again
Mobius probably turned it off themselves
they've got all kinds of emergency
protocols in place yes I agree they're
all dicks mighty Mobius being a grunt
the moment I become expendable well
that's when I start to look for the exit
door you get what I'm saying yeah I do
so you're gonna help me out or not I'll
help you out hell yeah but what clarify
I don't want to go back into the marrow
over there number one because in that
specific area that you specified is a
horrible monstrosity the likes of which
I was hoping to never see in my entire
existence that's what I was hoping for
and if you want to send me back down
there just know that I'm gonna be
emotionally scarred I just want you to
be aware of that fact that is gonna
happen I'm gonna be very scared and it's
not gonna be good for anybody might poop
my pants I'm just being honest
I'm being open as I possibly can I feel
like we're friends now and maybe we can
accept each other's poop pantsing nature
there's no workbench in here so I can't
craft anything all right
well see ya I've got one love you take
care bye all right whatever
well that wasn't a good sound boom
Sebastian here okay alright I can deal
with that hey I'm a pretty good dealer
of that with my things anyway here we go
not a very clever wordsmith second I can
talk to people okay so long as you don't
go sprinting off to the middle of
nowhere we're gonna get along just fine
boys Adam climb up on no truck in the
middle of me trying to sneak snog on you
oh good sound no no no you don't look
over there you go there you go she off
all right let me just grab this I'm
gonna grabbed it after I killed you I
guess but I wanna grab it now all right
where you gonna sprint off to today lady
oh boy okay just god I snakes knock over
this way you'll never hear me don't
don't don't don't don't don't don't do
no I'm coming Derro spamming my soup
button
[Laughter]
oh boy
okay alright whoa hello alright you can
jump over fences that's cool I can do
that not what I want to but I can do it
oh no I don't like that
your manoeuvres are a little twitchy and
I've ever told you how much I love the
look of your offset eyes ah your stained
dress charms me so oh my goodness the
with the perfect posture of your your
your gait your long legs your proclivity
to sprint he's really hungry go where am
I going
why does the camera always go crazy
every time every time no no no no no no
you don't know where I am
the ring-around-the-rosie indeed all
right thank you
Oh another one friend many friends do
help us through the night okay so we got
to get through oh yeah okay there we got
a lot of gunpowder which means that I'm
gonna be able to make pistol bullets
which is still not gonna help me but
hopefully these lock caches are gonna be
something more than I'm usin no I don't
want to go to the theater no I don't
want to go to the theater I just don't
know whoa ah it's a party over here
right good for you all of you you know
what's great you guys are so cool not
that I hate does this run for it because
I think it's a generally clear shot back
to the main
once we getting the marrow everything
will be hunky-dory and I'll be happy
forever all right but I don't want to go
back in the mirror you all know why oh
you don't want to go back in the marrow
I know that for a fact you yes the last
thing that we all collectively want it's
to go back into the marriage vows key oh
I don't care how enthusiastic Sebastian
is here it ain't good for nobody to go
back into that hellhole oh boy I'll save
downstairs but first let me get some
sweet delicious nectar of the Gods I
know I got ten pipes I'll get Ike I'm
gonna craft them crap them trust you me
trust you me I know I know no boy need
some coffee to steal my nerves to be
able to go back down where's a goddamn
work bench oh you're both right right
here okay all right well here we go I I
guess I can talk to that lady Heather
was her name Heather
it wasn't Heather was it no no no
here we go no for those of you who don't
know what's in the marrow why are you in
for a treat hey there's every chance
that maybe we're not going as far in
that we will see the horrible
monstrosity that we're being led to but
my sneaking suspicion is husky hey I'm
back oh why is this so creepy why is so
creepy here I remember it being nearly
this disturbing Lebowski hello surprise
were you you weren't looking at porn or
nothing were ya
oh I okay weird and creeping can I talk
to you no way oh but by the way nothing
by the way I hate you then goodbye
alright oh god damn it you drank this
coffee how could you where's your
goddamn work where's a workbench I could
have sworn there was a workbench in here
I'll say I just glossed it over but
apparently no I can go into the dream
world and get a workbench let me do that
when we maybe try one more time at the
shooting gallery to be able to do that
hmm oh also I got another slide I should
look at that yeah take a look if there's
any more story going on here yeah the
coffee heals magically and wonderfully I
don't know how but it dude
go on go on get out of here cat all
right Cadman pick up Kidman I'm here the
first time I saw Mayer she was wearing
that uniform I think I fell in love with
her right then in there I didn't want to
admit it to myself but after she was
injured on duty I knew I couldn't risk
not telling her how I felt she was such
a great wife and mother that I sometimes
forget she was a great detective too she
right she knew there was something fishy
about Lily's death
I mean kidnapping I should have believed
her from the start
it's me Kidman after beacon I tried to
make some sense of what happened to me
but everyone said I was delusional or
hiding the truth I started to believe
that maybe they were right that maybe I
was crazy yeah I'm so frustrated useless
he was the only thing that killed the
pain mmm so much time wasted I could
have tried harder don't make excuses for
me Kidman I [ __ ] up the time to make
up for it okay but true you're right
Kidman Thanks
oh that's so nice still think it means
your daughter this is weird who's taking
these pictures oh thank you thank you
kitty oh you're so sweet all right now
before I craft up I'm gonna try one more
time there's only one more level of this
thing because I've done all of these
I've gotten all the parts from there
there's just the chain attack and all I
gotta do is just think rationally about
the combos all right
I'm gonna go for red
there we go maybe maybe not even like
wait that long okay alright gonna go
Paul
wait a bit longer red okay got that
all right is red here blue that
okay good all blues next up because I'm
thinking logically about this
okay there we go oh that was a mistake
bah and I'm really phone synced up
aren't I
there we go okay okay what am i going
for what am I going for blue Blues next
blues next we go there we go there we go
okay
blues next okay okay there we go
what's next what's next was I don't know
I don't know what's next I'm gonna try
for blue eye oh god I just ruined blue
oh I'm the worst at this I'm the worst
blue
[Applause]
still looks like promising aspects no oh
no oh no it was shaky shimmying there we
go okay all right either red or red okay
it was shaky for just a second okay
oh no I did I've completely goof it up
completely goofed everything now
everything's been goofed and I have
nothing I have nothing I'm looking oh
geez I'm left so much nothing go give me
that and get at the time okay
oh that was bread that could have been
done but I again very odd stupid stupid
stupid made seven me I'm stupid I'm
stupid I'm stupid I'm stupid not bad
that was bad okay all right
I panicked I panicked I panicked from
the very GetGo I panicked which was
probably my first mistake and wallet
won't be my last but there we go got
that
we get that
okay we're doing great this is great
they're all it's just falling in my lap
Oh who'da thunk hold it
all right and then get you you
you you and you okay you oh this is
beautiful oh you and then oh you you you
and then you you you all fish wonderful
this is about as good as you could ever
hope for
right okay gonna go for rednecks layer
up those combos
and Bob's your uncle you got everything
okay
so I what I didn't know is that the
clocks actually cause the ones around it
to change color so if I can use that to
my advantage then I should be able to
get Prime any Christmas come on how is
it there we go okay now link up that red
link it up come on link it up oh all
right whatever
[Applause]
give me some we're adding some red miso
okay yes crap okay
well this looks like a whole lot of
nothing now
when Gibson read if anyone would grace
me with some red come on BAM okay
oh why that's awful
why would you do that this is so much
error
you know what I'm just gonna go go for
broke I've got the time I just need to
get no wait god damn it Mike my score I
was doing so good where's the combo
80,000 points in the first ten seconds
not bad I panicked again I panicked I
was doing great doing great
panics again I'm awful I'm terrible I'm
the worst I was doing great didn't do
great got it I got it this time I
panicked again
fine
I'm race
[Applause]
always better to calmly and collectedly
get those
[Music]
always bad
I'm only gonna hit those things when I
really need them cuz I don't always need
it right away you know okay
better to have loved and lost how is
that not a combo how is that not a combi
how is that not a combi how is that not
there we go okay blam blam
blam okay all right
blam there okay
blam blam blam blam blam
okay you and gray
[Music]
[Applause]
No God I was going for that one no I did
it again no man I just panicked shoot
for some reason oh I thought that was
gonna be oh I thought that was gonna be
I thought with all my heart all my heart
and so I thought I was gonna be okay
it's fine you're still in it okay
we're gonna go for gold because why not
everything except the gold nice get out
well it is
read it is
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes yes holy shed the best around
detective and nothing's ever gonna keep
me yeah I should probably get back to
that whole finding my daughter thing
[Laughter]
what what are you talking about
Sebastian stop talking nonsense
you crazy boss oh you don't even need to
craft on the table you crazy buffoon oh
man you are just the worst aren't you oh
geez okay all right that's funny okay so
what I got to do Oh what do I got to do
I have no idea what I gotta do what am i
doing what the hell am i doing here
I gotta get more firepower sure yeah
okay yeah let's do that
great and I need 800 and then I'll give
you a 50% boost holy that would be
amazing
okay I'll get that eventually right now
I just need more bullets there's so many
more bullets okay and all right and then
my vibes from the phones if those let's
get all of those so I can actually use
them I'd be nice for a change
again then syringes because I've been
using those come on don't be sassy with
me okay that's all that we got that
let's shoot some goop in my brain and
then we're gonna be off and back into
the marrow which is gonna be awful
terrible
all right now I upgrade my suit oh no
I'm not that close okay thank you I
forgot I had an extra syringe in here I
gotta use those actually I never end up
using those all right lockers fiddly
diddly Liddy did a little heed OOP oh
that's actually really good sniper rifle
bullets I don't need that I'm full up
but Wow
okay thank you all right let's see what
else we got you see more at ease
detective I did just win the possible
ally in this dangerous world not sure
about that I never know who to trust in
here I know how many's a shame after all
we've been through together isolation
and distrust aren't symptoms of mental
illness but they are unfortunate
byproducts of it closing yourself off
from others does nothing but agitate
your condition you are human you require
a connection the way a plant requires
light the only connection I require
right now is to your machine
I've still got a long road ahead of me
mm-hmm okay all right then well sure
let's go with that one there's nothing
wrong with being cautious you should
shut your face you I don't eat wait how
do i stun enemies then melee attacks do
more damage I would like that but
frankly on nightmare mode I don't even
know if that's good and old like any of
this but I'll take this cuz it's not
that expensive
recovery I don't need any of that
athleticism that would be useful the
whole avoiding damage thing
I guess I guess it would be having that
20% dodge
automatically evade enemy attacks with
set probability okay that's cool at
least I have the chance that's good
enough for now I got certain red gel but
I'm gonna wait till I get more brain
suit before I'm able to actually do that
blood soup
health or recovery what a bunch of
baloney I never get hit in this game why
would I need more health are you out of
your mind have you seen me play this I'm
an expert here we go okay we got to get
back into let's save real quick and then
we are jetting off into the way I saw a
comment earlier that was like wait I
just remembered what's in the marrow and
I'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah it's no
good it's no good here we go okay All
Right see ya lady let me lock it for you
you're welcome you could have locked it
yourself but okay alright alright okay
okay that's not what I wanted okay
whoops okay yep pretty sure that's
exactly where I need to go all right
here we go
was it I don't want to go in here I
don't hello
case you didn't know something horrible
is lying on the other side of these
walls
now this is bizarre the last time I came
through here I swear it was a lot more
goopy yeah pretty sure last time I came
through here
it was way goofier than this now
ordinarily you know in a normal
situation you'd be like oh thank
goodness it's less goopy in here just
makes me more concerned just makes me
infinitely more concerned you know I'll
take familiarity over the unknown any
day all right
Castellanos here with a crossbow poon
any coupon to get pooned let me know got
a lot of pipe oh this is undoped that's
that's lovely nice chest I wall okay
seems like that worked
yes I should go back to sites
it's a lot of goodies but still I I know
that's a lot of goodies more goodies
than I was expecting
Topolsky I don't do subtle oh I missed
of course I missed hang on wait let me
try that again
there we go six fun to negotiate with
you what did I get up oh no I got an axe
already have one of those well that's Oh
mister what were you thinking Oh
ambushed there we go all right whatever
soup for you oh god I can't feed soup
into your back face all right whatever
thank you you for your contribution
right well
mm-hmm I'm just gonna assume that the
goop monster is gone all right you want
to come around this corner which corner
you're gonna come around I just want to
know where where where the soup needs to
go can I ambushed you please please
please please come on let me ambush you
a little closer and yeah I just need to
talk to you oh no what was that did I
hear some this is my grandmother's
recipe peculiar about that huh weird I
swear I smell some soup over here Wow
you were you turn around okay all right
no need to throw a temper tantrum here I
could do that but now that would have
been a bad idea
well they call me the jumping suit man
alright would you like some clam chowder
uh-oh that's another grunt oh hello
grunty huh peculiar how your friend just
got suped you're gonna are you worried
about that at all maybe here's a free
bottle sample mmm that's an enticing
deal buy one get one free you say oh
[Laughter]
really I shouldn't give these guys
personality something's inhuman makes me
almost not want to soup him right in the
eyes
pocket soup just got it some soup I got
one pocket full of spaghetti one pocket
full of soup to combine it for a world's
worst fireball what if I went to a LARP
session and I just had pockets full oh
how do you tell a kilt full of soup and
I'm just like yeah that's 20 damage you
need to fall down now thank you
early with enough of my ridiculous world
I don't think there's any goop happening
over here
ooh that's a fun noise oh it's lady lady
I can take care of lady I know how to
treat a lady
alright well why can't i well then we're
gonna look that way I suppose
we go I don't think she's especially
nothing you can't sprint on this one oh
yes you can
come on ski Oh still hungry I can hardly
believe it oh this ain't good
you didn't hear nothing weird how there
was nothing weird how that soup came
from nowhere it's like it's like the
movie ghost but instead of molding clay
its soup directly into your anus alright
yep sure okay alright
whole lot of nothing huh all right there
okay all right easy peasy
you know without these sneaking skills I
doubt I would have gotten through this
game because I would have been wasting
too much ammo there's and been so
frustrated with everything there's no
way you have to have the sneaking skill
you gotta have your sneaking shoes you
can't go anywhere without your sneaking
shoes okay well thankfully well all
right Sebastian your legs are just a
hilarious situation all together but all
that aside I've got there's there's
important work to do here
why does that look like a real room
alright whatever
boom did I go in here have I been in
here probably right yeah definitely now
take a devil boom okay alright lady okay
not caboose key on that one all right
well apparently we didn't meet the giant
just monster which is a phrase I always
loved saying out loud but we got what we
needed so good for me a bogey
okay so we got to get back to Sykes
because apparently Sykes now has a way
that we can get out here
which is good I think anyway if I can
trust Sykes because you never know who
you can trust in here actually I'd trust
sex over pretty much everyone I met so
far better than Liam oh potatoes way
back in the beginning who's probably
dead probably if I just had to guess
probably extremely dead yeah maybe I
should've told everyone to like you know
meet forward like go to the next mark
then put kicks open a door that's me I'm
I never said I was highly intelligent
just that I was extremely handsome I
where am I going oh yeah let me save and
then I'm gonna keep going I'm gonna
report back to sex but I'm gonna hit
that one case on the way here because if
I can get that then I'm hunky-dory so
all good all good all good all good
ohyeah all right one of these days I'm
gonna lock that door and turn around
there's gonna be just a huge laughing
over me okay so and this light off vault
over this for no reason doodlee doodlee
d man my stamina is so much better okay
mmm forgot there was so much moaning in
this area
all right give me that sweet delicious
case do they pile up bodies just in the
hopes that they'll all turn into a
horrible conglomeration it's just a
terrible thought to think of but so what
I'm thinking of right now ten bullets
that's totally worth it totally worth
going back in there totally worth it but
only totally worth it because I didn't
face the giant goopy monster all right
let's see I can sneak snuck in the back
way kind of the back way
not really the back way but back enough
there's so many of you all in one
position yeah that's right get out of
here hell is real and it's here now way
to complain there's no other monsters on
the way from here to the safe house
right okay good because after this I'm
going to be loaded up all right hope I
didn't alert anyone to you no one can
get through this door no one could
possibly get around this door in what
universe would somebody be able to get
in that safe area I sure love your
armored tarp there that's really gonna
keep people out oh good thing I locked
this oh good cuz we all know they can't
climb anything as judged by the bus we
saw in the last area here yeah I unlike
the supply containers just like I
promised okay if you can open that one
there I've already opened two but let's
see let's see what happens let's see
I should opened it before I got here
but yah Oh who's just like just like a
pie in the face and sex is over there
just laughing up a storm he's the team
prankster my sneaking skill my soup
delivery device is no now has a stealth
mode yes what I've always wanted
can you really do it get out of Union
like I said I'm gonna give it my best
shot
but there's a ton of data I gotta scrub
through before I can even start I just
hope I can do it before this place turns
into a pile of gravel and guts it's
gonna take me a while okay any of you
see what happens if you get out of Union
if I can make it out of the Mobius
building alive first thing I'm gonna do
is disable my damn chip chip yeah
everybody in Mobius has got a subdermal
chip in their head
sort of like an RFID but way more
advanced and I mean everybody from the
administrator all the way down to the
guy who cleans the toilets mm-hmm and
you submit to that willingly
like they say membership has its
privileges that chip will open a lot of
doors for you if you got one
the downside is with that chip in place
they can make my life a living hell if
they think I disobeyed them I guess you
can worry about that if you make it out
of here mmm I might be interested in
getting out of here - you're welcome -
but I'm not gonna wait around for you
I'm leaving here as soon as I find a way
your best bet is to hang out here with
me and wait until I figure this out no
way I'm not leaving this place without
Lily theoretically if you find her
you'll restore this place and get
yourself out I'd prefer to take Lily at
the back door with me Mobius just wants
to plug her back into stem god knows
what they've got planned for me if we
could just get out when they're not
looking well either way listening in on
Wes nobody's using the back door let's
pair up our communicators call me before
you leave yeah okay good luck out there
all right so how are they not listening
in to these conversations is what I want
to know how do they not know exactly
what we're planning and what we're doing
here how do they not know that with that
chip in your head you know and how
you're in a bathtub that they're
standing around with monitors hooked up
to your brain and such as the like as
that what what are you what are you
saying that maybe then maybe that's not
a good idea to be shouting this out out
loud
or Who am I Who am I kidding this place
is so secure there's no way people could
hear anything that we're saying it's the
most isolated place in the world
shotgun sack
all right anyway better get that shotgun
sack hello and gun bullets
I like those those are nice where are we
talking about here well don't see the
handgun bullets
I didn't log onto it that's my bed and
that's me that's me getting overexcited
nope I locked on to that dad don't make
sense I swear I don't got nothing wait
the answers right in front of me the
answer has been in front of me all along
sighs do you have handgun bullets on you
all right anyway I ignore that gonna
ignore that murderous urge in my brain
something tells me Mobius wanted me to
shoot Sykes I can't imagine why we were
talking about such nice things over here
all right oh there it is it's in the
corner over there okay perfect perfect
for me
I can finally fill my sack ah perfect
I've been waiting so long to fill my set
I coulda sworn this was busted open
oh no they climbed over that's right
okay all right look get those bullets
and then I'm gonna move on to the
shotgun pouch
I have everything I need everything I
could possibly want in life would be
available to me right then and there -
OH - ah - really why even waste my time
with your dead body why even bother gosh
I'm mad now that you all right looking
herb maybe this will sways my anger whoa
okay that's that's not good you
definitely know okay maybe not
I'm sure wish you would let me in on the
joke all right must be down this alley
then all right well there I go but I
gotta remember there was a sprinting
lady that caught me in the Tommy in the
open I'll smash open these boxes don't
you worry
oh I'm gonna I've hardly worth it okay
whatever oh I hear that
I see where you are okay
can I climb over this thing
what can okay how about a jumpin ambush
how about jump stealthy old the opposite
of good not good not good not good okay
alright well that didn't go as planned
well sure hope laughing lady doesn't
come down that alley
that would be precarious and bad for
care okay good prepare a bad maybe maybe
I can have this terrifying that might be
the scariest thing I've ever seen in my
life
oh boy there she goes okay well that
this isn't gonna work out I highly doubt
I'm gonna be able to super around the
corner sweet soup ambush keep doing that
okay all right I'm gonna jump over go
forward jump over those boxes that you
mistakenly jumped over like an idiot
alright where are you gonna be here I'll
Pat your ass in a second I just got a
deal I know I'll do it now I'm brave Oh
didn't he pass Oh shot gun pouch my sac
all right where are you at lady
for a second there I thought your voices
got really deep very word I can't oh
okay yeah you know what this is also one
of the scariest things I've ever seen in
my life it's terrifying in every way
nope don't do that you better turn
around because I don't think I can
ambush around this corner Oh No okay all
right so we got the sack we got that I
don't see any other signals over here
there was something in the building here
there was like some building that I
could go in over here which was weird
I probably shouldn't go in it again
all right I'm gonna go I'm gonna go in
that weird building I could go in before
but I didn't go in probably gonna lead
to my death oh sweet I've got a lot of
materials not a lot I got a lot of
clothes hello Jorge Bastian Castellanos
in a hurry hey you can't come in here
laughs up a storm out there who's
laughing now lady maybe lady you're a
lot of different work you know I don't
want to offend you so I'm I'm out I go
say anything brain goop ha Bisky alright
there's a fuse in there then not what I
was hoping for come on give me that soup
oh there it is hmm it's a sweet
vegetable beef oh my favorite
alright there we go what's up here I got
I got a feeling I'm gonna hear Lala lady
up here by if I have any sneaking
suspicion about who don't like that
already don't like this okay
yep don't like that that's bad that's no
good but why though but but but why
though but but but why though why but
why though well these are locked wait
they're locked but then maybe that means
I can get in I don't know all right
bizarre but okay I just got that shivers
all of a sudden I have no idea why that
creeped me out
that's weird let me honk a bar no you're
gonna honk the bus but yeah I changed
suddenly for some reason I changed my
mind about Hong Kong in that bus seems
like a bad idea this juncture ain't
going there okay we're good let's just
go for it you want let's stop wasting
time stop being a silly Billy get over
there
excuse me lady go over here and get down
to business
we got a lot of business to take care of
and we can finally go back
oh you yeah I forgot about you oh I
could forget about you know maybe if you
paid more attention to me a bit more
attention to you I was with this guy in
like and oh I thought that was a lake or
something or like a puddle that's that's
actually a chasm okay whatever I'll go
around play your game you rogue if you
want to play a game I got games to play
with you get over it can't client I
can't climb over that rock
Olo lady oh all right well that's good
for me I'm the worst about getting those
keys but hey doing pretty good now wow
these bushes ain't gonna these bushes
hide my lover legs perfectly all right
wait I forgot um I want to put the
change type I of course of course I'm
going with the silenced handgun unless
the silence handgun doesn't have all the
upgrades of the not silenced handgun
does it does it work like that cuz if it
does I'm gonna be pissed because I spent
so long up writing my not cuz this only
has six bullet oh there we go seven okay
I'm assume I'm gonna assume it's
upgraded cuz if it's not I'm gonna be
very pissed all right there we go
I want the silence always nice meat
sculpture oh and by nice I mean please
stop please stop please please stop the
hell are these things about I don't know
damn lilies inside there how do you know
the lease inside there is it the big cat
wha is the became ER and sky Oh
nope nope don't want that I don't want
to listen to no echoes art time to put
Hoffman's theory to the test
what was Hoffman theory I can't believe
they forgot what it was uh lust for art
I got a lust up some art
Zota gotta do
[Music]
I should have come here first I would
have oh that's awful
nope hate that nope don't like that that
is the worst thing that is the worst
thing yeah I should have gone for that
first then I would have been exploring
the town and actually
that's what the painting was all about I
tried to destroy it I tried I really
tried but alas it just didn't work
you know all right well I'm gonna Mandor
down the street and fulfill my destiny
I guess all right I don't wanna miss I
don't want to tango with you guys come
on now get with it people ketchup and
mustard was like shiny shiny ketchup ah
perfect I'll add that to my soup refried
bean soup okay speaking of soup my dad
my dad made this um made this like it's
more of a stew than a soup but it was
just he basically put a bunch of beans
in a pot and he cooked it real slow
overnight and he put it like they can do
it and some ham and it was delicious but
the enhancement of that one that he did
was he dumped ketchup in it like right
on top of it just like ketchup all over
it and you know I loved that too but now
looking back on it might been a little
weird that seems like it seems a little
weird to me to dump ketchup in soup but
I I did it you know and I did and I
loved it it was great but I'm
questioning it I don't know why anyway
totally off topic ketchup soup is not a
thing but putting ketchup in a soup is a
thing that I have done in my life just
so we're all it's down this way around
this corner hey wait wait yeah I want to
see if they're still there are they
still here are my dancing boys still
here are they are they still please tell
me they're still please please tell me
they're still here I just need a smile
in my life I just need something hey off
listen to look closely yeah oh yeah
there's still a oh god I love him I love
him so much
look at those guys ah you're perfect
look at you you're so skilled Oh keep it
up guys
I know there's like there's nails over
there and those a gun butter over there
but you know what I think this is like
sacred ground
I there they put this garbage truck here
to block off their ritual here they're
just having fun there's nothing nothing
suspicious about it all they're just
having fun and you know I do am I to
spoil their fun I'm not gonna spoil
their fun not gonna spoil their for sale
okay oh oh oh all right anybody in here
a plan let me set up by the roots
jukebox jukebox you slam that bad boy no
okay all right then hello bottles thank
you mmm now that's art someone said now
that's art now I agree that's art what
what Stefano's doing over there that
ain't art well that's going on there the
dancing circles ami that's art all right
final entry in this well-worn journal
the taprooms being been booming business
is good lots of new faces in Union these
days they're arriving by the trainload
and they're thirsty if it keeps up like
this I'll finally be able to afford some
beer taps Pete complains about the
crowds but I say the more the merrier
he's always been cantankerous but lately
he's been acting extra weird he sits
there in his usual spot giving new
customers the stink eye and mumbling to
himself cut him off but he's always been
my best customer hmm is that the same
guy who went to Jukes diner and shot
himself I don't like all this smashed up
glass here this bottle didn't help you
none but it might help me all right I'm
behind here anybody well this is art
it's just a photo photo of some very
very dead people which is the more
concerning thing Oh
Bart's thank you all right I've almost
got the 800 I need for the final upgrade
for the pistol
mmm don't like it ah I'm so glad that
Sebastian and I are always on the same
page here cuz that was exactly my
thought gotta find a key or something
I'm gonna stab the [ __ ] out of you I'm
gonna try the exact same approach to the
other painting as well okay it's just
it's just a fact like you may call me
unoriginal but I'm nope don't like that
no
oh I can't concentrate like this a
sculpture doesn't well though I can see
that oh what's that oh present okay all
bullets
something tells me yeah but I have to
use them like you you know what there's
there's there there are situations that
I would need the silenced but there's
also situations that I would need the
not silenced version so I can always
just come in here alright yeah it's fine
it's fine it's fine
it's all good okay so cuz they did say
the silas version does less damage so
there's something oh I see you what you
doing
okay alright
there's something at the
okay all right all right okay all right
I see you game you're playing okay it's
all right this is all good okay all
right well easy enough you don't even
have an axe right there you could have
gotten oh you would have had me so good
oh you would have had me so good well
maybe this isn't the ideal place to be
you know what oh come on how even how
are you gonna you telling me
you telling me do you somehow sniff me
out of there I disagree
sure just cuz I'm carrying so much soup
doesn't mean that you can detect it it's
condensed you have to add for the other
one go I know oh I knew I heard him okay
let's see if I can Bush this guy hey
come on down hey come on down to big
market soup and Boreum hey don't make me
come to you oh come on now you know you
want try a free sample Oh
shy customer shy customer shy customer
is everything no just just entice him a
little hey sir
come on Missy free sample it's good it's
good stuff come on down come on down
oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah nah
don't be shy come on now come out of the
darkness come a little closer a little
closer to please look oh come on down
little closer low close your body boo
Oh what was that ah there we go
do you like it you like it tell your
friends all right thank you
somebody here that goes with the thumpy
alright whatever you say whatever you
mumble oh you didn't see nothing oh
that's a that's a sprinty lady oh yeah
oh I heard about the soup sale please ah
was it over here I'm an idiot so I don't
really know oh that ain't good
that's okay though I think I can manage
all right
Oh God why do i why does it do that no
no no no no I hate that it's just like
okay that's not ideal no no - you don't
know where I am
youyou suspects you don't know though my
footsteps so soft soft like butterfly
wings yeah okay yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah no no yeah oh no
okay all right okay all right all right
the last bowl for you there we go oh is
that one still bashing on the door did
that guy go to look cool
yes it was nothing time to go wham on
this door some more
that's all I wouldn't that's all I'll
ever do alright sure hope all my friends
part oh it changed his mind he changes
his life story is changed it is he heard
someone talking [ __ ] alright okay what
are you gonna do you're gonna go back to
it oh no no no oh why didn't I just
ambush him there I'm dumb well you know
glad we answer that riddle I am dumb
well every single one of you guys didn't
like my very possible to overdose here
this is how this is how you Whangdoodle
a gate sir let me show you how it's did
yeah
but Sebastian Castellanos real strong
yeah sorry you're so wimpy oh it's my
wrist okay oh hello again friend are you
doing
okay I got a key which is awfully nice I
don't like that no I changed my mind I
like it okay this is the opposite of
good okay so I got a sneaks knock my way
through this is what you're saying well
sure I don't think you know how good my
sneaks knocking skills are and I have to
say they are incredible okay wait a
minute I don't think I can get over you
all right let's take another route my
okay that's all so I can't exactly oh
there we go here we go yes I knew there
was a way for me hmm very scary but I'm
not scared
precarious thing I'm so speeding I hope
you're right about destroying these
things yes
wait did Hoffman suggest that who visit
Tate's quiz
okay got it ooh that's why are they all
tied to you about who write up we get in
the bus hey yeah OOP
it wasn't exactly a stab the [ __ ] out of
situation but it was there's definitely
a slice eat I see destroying that freaks
work was actually therapeutic yeah one
more one more
I know where it is hopefully there's not
a big giant laughing Lady Luck in my
path that would be the word that's not a
door that's a window all right up there
she is oh shoot
she heard me talking [ __ ] again oh wait
Hannah I can do this wait if I do this
come here
walk right through the water right
through the water right through the
water and oh oh oh oh no for you oh just
look tiniest like slightest steps from
Sebastian they're like doodle you gotta
have dainty toes when you're running
away from that thing Oh be talking [ __ ]
again good that's what I gotta stop
doing it always gets me in trouble up
well ran a stamina I am in trouble oh no
she's slow she's slow it's fine she's
still being shocked she's good she's
good all right that's good it's all good
oh there's two wait no what no cheating
cheating let me show you what I do to
cheaters we just blow them up and then
shock him again maybe we'll see about
wonder which one it oh yeah charge
charge start charge come on don't be shy
little skadoodle Ewok hilarious alright
well that didn't work out as hopefully
as good as I went it's good to come here
come on what's it gonna what's arm
what's arm yeah oh well I should've
reloaded
I meant to do more of this action oh
well I wasted a lot on the okay you know
what I shouldn't have tried that that's
the moral of the story I shouldn't try
there we go okay vamos key all right
what was that
[Applause]
okay all right anyway the one and done
is appear I think she learned her lesson
yeah I think she learned her lesson okay
here we go
I'm gonna stab the [ __ ] out of you here
comes the stab train
let's finish this oh okay all right then
not ideal not ideal ooh aah
I thought I killed you no I didn't kill
you I just postponed you didn't I
yeah well this is an ominous hallway
okay got better got that bit about okay
right where'd she go
I did not miss your moaning oh look a
key perfect good thing my sneaking so
spare you all right this should get me
close to that heart
good good whoa hey don't stand off
speech knock maybe I can sneak by Oh
Sebastian I've been waiting my whole
life for you to say those words to me
which way you which way you step
stepping I don't know where you is but
don't like that that's the opposite of
what I prefer okay all right well easy
enough with these sneaking shoes
anything's possible I warmed up oh sorry
yeah you're just terrible
hopefully I'm done with those things for
a while probably not I would guess
that's a big no all right next on amber
okay
ah why this again why this why why this
why this okay all right you know what
I've added up to here with your
silliness I'm gonna go this way now cuz
I got a good feeling about it oh yeah
there we go oh that was easy oh wait
that was easy
I got Oh scary okay ah it's very scary
okay right I have become the craze but
stepper all right well there we go got
him Oh God
cool beans Hoffman I don't know what I
think Hoffman's advice was more like you
know allegory and I took it literally in
two of them so stab stab back to the
theater and see if I can get in
you want me stabbed Hoff man [ __ ] man
you want stab me no soup but I also know
stabbed stabbed best way to get soup in
person or zombie sorry specifically
zombie me only talked about zombie not
not stabbing person anyway also oh it's
brighter out wait that's weird
wait um it's brighter out right I'm not
crazy
also what's back here cuz I know the
dancing zombies were over there but
what's back here and I can go around if
I can go around this way I just want to
check it before I go over to the theater
just in case I miss anything else like I
don't want to miss out on this okay an
herb good start good start good start I
like it I like interesting architecture
all right also good oh there's no way to
go back here it was all a lie
alright well fine then but why is it
getting brighter
oh you're so tall oh oh well this ain't
good
you know now I know why she's laughing
that's also funny oh boy what I died I
wasn't even talking [ __ ] I wasn't I
swear my mouth was not [ __ ] talking oh
boy well this is gonna be a thing all
right come on come on come on come on
someday I'll finish you off but you know
not today yeah oh boy I almost sucker
look that's a dead end I shouldn't go
that way I'd be a bad idea that was too
close
ah too close to my tokus all right where
am I going here am I is there even a oh
why do you have a bag oh no that's not
the body
oh god this is uh this is not good oh my
leg just went a funky thing they're very
tired very tired gotta rest the old you
know I don't want to waste this on you
okay oh stop stop stop stop you get the
old air stomped to you oh there we go
take that come here oh what's that you
know what this isn't worth it is it
what no come on what oh god no this is
the opposite of what oh no oh this is
all bad all bad just literally the worst
it could possibly do I wanted to try to
get this kick my kicking skills are so
bad all right lady
now good thing I got some coffee waiting
for me
oh boy you know what forget that forget
that forget I'm out of stamina I want to
come back for all of this okay well
there goes my head you know it was bad
news to just go down there in the first
place
that was my mistake should've gone to
the save point but there was a lot of
supplies down there if I can get away
from the big lady that is totally worth
going down there oh man
well that was mistake like from start to
finish that was horrible this lady I saw
something in here did I maybe I don't
know those lady tonight honk the horn
hey do you have anything on you have a
sack honk oh there's weird bus honking
who knew those business
[Music]
no oh boy do not coming oh she tried to
get on the bus
oh she thought she could steer me maybe
she was just trying to give me like you
know all those bouncy rides that would
have been fun would have been fun wasn't
fun okay she's not following me yeah I
think I'm in the clear
okay then I can get down this this way
get all the supplies that I need over
here know why heard those stumps ooh
lady no that's a sign
someone's answering my clarion call at
the bus by bus honking who's home can
overhear oh no my favorite sports team
go oh oh all right well oh yeah take
your briefcase out of here okay
oh that's right I should use this for
silent kill sometimes you know sometimes
I really think about it well I mean
number one I have to have good aim but
you know which I don't hey can you stand
real still please let's see you stand
real nope missed
well you ducked not my fault she ducked
who is honking time to engage sneak mode
not good at the whole shooting oh why
lady lady lady no there's literally no
way you know where I am
that would be impossible to think of
such a thing could be oh boy here we go
[Applause]
oh come on now come on now come on I'm
just gonna okay I'm just gonna you know
I'm just gonna try to get out of here
around the Rosie okay look an exploding
barrel maybe I could use that to my
advantage okay here we go problem good
thing these ten metal walls are here
okay all right thank you still alive in
here might be a giant laughing lady
coming through the walls with a saw
that's really not a good idea probably
not a good idea okay all right so I am
all out of time for today thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm gonna
be back again tomorrow morning at 8:00
a.m. Pacific Standard Time I don't know
if I'm always gonna be streaming at 8:00
a.m. it's just something that worked out
well for me
in the current weeks but there's a lot
of things I want to do in the morning
but for at least tomorrow and the next
day I will be streaming back tomorrow at
8:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time with the
evil within and another video coming out
in noon pacific today in about two and a
half hours so thank you everybody so
much for joining thank you everybody so
much for commenting thank you everybody
so much for being here as I get the poop
scared out of me and I will take care of
these problems in the next episode
thanks again as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye bye bye bye boy
bye guys bye
boy